let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
how far
and henry kissinger [ __ ] off
i don't know how far
someone who's a thousand years old can
[ __ ] off but to me
it would be all the way
all the way he can [ __ ] off
uh
i guess it's not surprising that uh a
putin lover like henry kissinger would
say oh ukraine that sovereign nation
that democracy needs to give away part
of their land
to the murderous dictator
because
he is one
i didn't know that [ __ ] was
still alive who
honestly i thought he was taking a dirt
nap
i mean you know
sounds about time for one but really
honestly i i
every time he says something or someone
says he says something
it's like that mother he's still alive
how old is that [ __ ] apparently
he's 99 years old
it seems like he's a thousand though
like he was 99 years old in the 1980s
the other thing is the doctor thing the
doctor thing
doctor henry kissinger
oh
ricky gervais is in the news
for making off-handed jokes about trans
folks
you know what's weird what's gonna be
really strange about this ricky gervais
thing
is all these right-wing christians who
are claiming the only thing that matters
is their religion
only their religion like they're willing
to take away people's liberty women's
liberty
because they believe when
a guy ejaculates or even thinks about
even gets a boner if a guy gets a boner
that's a human being that's a baby
that
is a baby
religion is so important but i i i damn
well bet
damn well bet
that you're gonna see a lot of horrible
takes from the right about how great
ricky gervais is
as you guys know ricky gervais is
very very very famous as a comedian for
being an atheist
outspoken atheist
and they're going to be like oh ricky
gervais is the best ever in the history
of ever ever
which i mean really honestly when we
when we take a look
at some of the jokes
that ricky gervais actually told like i
wouldn't try to watch the clip
to see some of the offhanded jokes that
he was making
and ricky gervais is making us talk
about
what you should and should not say
about another human being
that's the conversation that we're
having now i know i don't think that
that was ricky gervais's his aim here i
don't think he had this grand scheme
to make off-handed jokes
about a marginalized group of people
so that way the world would have a
conversation i do not think that's the
case
now it is happening
right now because richard gervais is
is trending trans is trending
and the world is having this
conversation along with state farm we
see state farm
they announced that they were going to
support
lgbtq
books in schools
and the right wing lost their [ __ ]
minds
because of god and religion
and they love to use the word groomer
lost their [ __ ] minds and state farms
like oh yeah we don't wow
gay people we don't like gay people we
forget about that forget about that
i guess jake from state farm
you guys remember the jake from state
farm commercial right
what's her name jake
you remember you remember
the jake from state farm khaki
commercial
a lot of people bought state farm i've
never actually
i've never been insured by state farm
several others that are like state farm
but not state farms specifically
not not because you know i'm some kind
of woke justice warrior i just never did
business with state farm
they were always more expensive
pretty simple pretty simple they always
had to have a gimmick like jake from
state farm
but it looks like
state farm
continues their gimmick
when they pretend to support
the lgbtq community
by saying yeah we support we support
books and schools
that show
lgbtq
community in books
the religious writer like oh
we are very insecure about our sexuality
we cannot make sure
that people know that i might be gay
that's literally that's literally the
[ __ ] ploy here from the right wing
when they say groomer they mean they're
the groomers literally there's dozens
dozens of cases already this year where
elected republican officials
have been arrested for either child porn
or underage prostitution
rape
incest molestation jesus [ __ ] christ
that guy
that donald trump endorsed in the
nebraska governor's race was accused of
groping
he didn't drop out donald trump's like
oh well i support him
he's he's a fellow [ __ ] grabbers though
and they're worried about state farm
acting like their allies in the lgbtq
community
and i say acting like because it's
obvious they were acting they were
pretending
pretending to be an ally
that's what state farm
did
that's why you shouldn't always buy into
this or that it's like this disney [ __ ]
that they keep going on and on and on
about well disney's no [ __ ] hero here
in the don't say gay bill
they were in support of it before they
were against it
and their employees had to tell them to
go [ __ ] off
and not support it they were gonna
strike
until the ceo came to his senses when
his employees said no you [ __ ] you need
to be against this thing
this woke stuff
this woke [ __ ]
that they keep talking about how
everyone's woke you're woke you're woke
i'm super woke
it's all to distract us from what is
really happening
to call us woke or you get paid by
george soros you're a soros whatever the
[ __ ] they say
i don't know i've been accused of being
paid by soros i haven't got my [ __ ]
george soros checked yet
not a god damn dime from that
[ __ ] him or bill gates speaking
of bill gates
elon musk
apparently believes everything that's
written in the
in the gossip rag the fake news that is
breitbart
believes it hook line sinker
especially
when they write about bill gates
he falls for it that's our title today
gullible elon falls for bart breitbart
look
i can't help it
when i get a chance
to [ __ ] dump on elon that's probably
what we're gonna do here
take a big old big huge tour [ __ ]
right on elon good morning everybody it
is a tuesday morning a beautiful tuesday
morning because we have you here live
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific holy moly look at the listeners
today
amanda hello christina megan's here
kinky streets i like that
i like to be able to say that username
kathy is here mayo good morning
stephanie is here debbie from salt lake
nancy is here forest matt midas robin
ron mj good morning
megan's here
shelly margie deborah from facebook is
here
boy we just have a ton of new listeners
to give you an idea what this show's
about
we go through the politics every single
weekday
on monday through friday for two full
hours live on youtube twitter twitch
and we simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page we are proud partners of
midas touch
shout out to all the minus mighty out
there
so here's the deal go subscribe to the
youtube channel just go to youtube and
type in the tony michaels if you're on
facebook that link is right there at the
post just go ahead and click on that
link and subscribe you are not going to
want to miss a thing uh we're going to
talk about today for a bit with gabe
sanchez my co-host and executive
producer a little bit about the public
hearings that are coming up
hint folks there's a there's a
preliminary schedule that has dropped it
looks like instead of eight hearings
they're gonna have six there's gonna be
two in prime time and four in the
morning
morning time
and we are going to cover every single
one of them all six
um hopefully the schedule stays pretty
solid here
and we're also gonna try to
we're also gonna try and get
uh more folks in for commentary during
those days during the the hearings
uh some people are saying that super
chat is not working yeah i don't know
what happened with youtube i'm gonna
have to fix that um when we get off the
air i noticed it right before we came on
but we will get that fixed
today so tomorrow we'll have
come back tomorrow in the super chat and
we'll have that
but here's the thing
we are going to
get
those hearings out to as big audiences
we can live streaming
and make sure
that we have commentary me and gabe will
be commentating we're gonna have some
other folks commentating uh probably
karen ignipolo kfa and michael popock
from legal af hopefully we'll get the
mizellas brothers from midas touch on
here during that live stream
uh we'll probably have some other
guests to announce as we get closer and
closer to those hearings as we know more
about the schedule but what it looks
like right now is there's six hearings
two prime time
four of them in the morning but it
appears that they'll kind of overlap
with the show so we'll probably just
do the hearings and that will be the
show we will continue on until what is
regularly the show's end
and those will become the episodes for
those days because it's just two of
those days during the showtime period
that's what i'm thinking so far
but we definitely need you guys to hear
or listen and and help
get the word out about these hearings
because the more people that see these
hearings i believe the better
i believe the better
so we will we stay tuned to that we're
going to talk about that a little bit
more today
but boy do we have a lot of news to get
to today there is a lot of stuff in the
news um
rachel maddow did a piece on the um
now that the insurrectionist you've seen
this guy the guy that gave the uh the
tour of the
of the capitol um we also of course we
have ricky gervais and kissinger
kissinger in the in the news alec
baldwin is in the news i guess i don't
know why he's trending word tech data
noah is trending noaa
it's the weather service that predicts
hurricanes they're predicting a very
very bad hurricane season again i guess
the seventh in a row
you know state farm is trending uh mo
brooks is trending
because today's primaries today is
primary day folks
are you voting are you in a state that
can vote i'm gonna talk about the
georgia race
and i'm gonna talk about uh republican
self-suppression um this is beautiful
this is how we need to draw wedges i'm
gonna show you this morning why the
republicans
are going to lose and how we can get
them to lose
that's right folks that's why voter
suppression
happens
on both sides
and you know a little bit encouragement
can go a long way to destroy fascism so
maybe that's what we should do
that's what we should do with our
messaging yeah and they do it with their
own messaging i'll show you what i mean
here in just a few minutes uh kellyanne
conway is trending novalny is trending
of course i think navalny's probably
trending because henry kissinger said oh
well you know what you know what ukraine
should do they should just give up part
of their sovereign country to vladimir
putin
they should just give it up just give it
up deal with it [ __ ] it just give it to
him
that because he'll definitely go away
after they give up territory you know
like the crimea
yeah you just give up territory and then
he'll just go away he'll stop committing
war crimes if you just give him what he
wants [ __ ] him [ __ ] putin and [ __ ] henry
kissinger [ __ ] him
that guy needs to take a nap
maybe a long
long
long dirt nap
let's get to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
the tony michaels podcast we have
reached the part of the show that is
called the [ __ ] list roundup where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends of today
boy do we have some stuff for you and
looky here
um
we have uh i want to show you this
before we get into a lot of the news i
want to show you
this um
yep that well if i can make my
i think ariel hey looky look at who we
have here
gabe sanchez good morning gabe
good morning tony
have you seen the trendy trends yet have
you seen all the stuff that's trending
it's it's uh it's kind of all over the
place this morning it is quite a sight
it is it is it's it's getting um
have you seen this tweet that i sent out
about candace taylor candace taylor is
the crazy kook she's the one that wants
to wants god to gun down babies have you
seen your campaign ads is that the the
guns baby no god guns god's god's babies
yes right
yeah those are the three magic words
right i don't know winning campaign
right god's guns babies but it sounds
like because she didn't put like periods
or anything she just like crams these
words together she's like god one two
three you know god guns babies down
there
ain't
i don't know what the [ __ ] is
there was a moment um
where she took it where her uh her
campaign bus like made its debut right
and everyone was like
you know what would the name
god's guns babies before right and be
like oh it was a country band or a song
it was like uh
like it was just like all the wrong
answers
um
but yeah it's one of those uh it's it's
a great great slogan
um
oh she's got some
she's got some doozies like this
there's there is no um turds nuttier
than this squirrel third here uh because
i'm gonna i'm gonna go back and show
some video of this this whack-a-doo but
this morning she tweets this this is at
8 46 a.m this is central time so it's 9
46 in georgia where she's running for
governor right um here's what she says
major issues in counties all over the
state so she's she's
she's they're already putting it out
there speed yeah yeah a voter fraud
scanners listen to scanners won't work
my phone is blowing up and then of
course she gives a remembers
romans 8 28. right and 8 28 uh
apparently silly it's 8 46 am you dumb
dumb
and what is what does rome have to do
with this yeah right it's like yeah rome
did fall right maybe she's saying
the scanners won't work the election is
rigged democracy will fall
just like the romans did
at 8 28
a.m or maybe she says p.m maybe it's pm
and half pm because that's when the
polls close
so candace taylor prediction
the election for georgia will fall with
democracy
just like the romans at 8 28 p.m
georgia time q yeah you got it you got
to put a q oh q right right
this this lady this lady is definitely a
wackadoo she says some crazy ass [ __ ]
um
i mean just absolute bonkers type [ __ ]
she actually said
[ __ ] over the weekend about natives and
indigenous people like yeah we came over
here and killed them and oh yeah
yeah and that was that was a video
wasn't that yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna try
to see if we can find that um but she
but this tweet here
is really sewing doubt about the
election and it's not
it's not like it's good for her right
this isn't good for republicans i here's
i'm gonna say her tweet sucks because it
it definitely sucks let's just get that
out of the way right now right let's
just let's just say that yeah that tweet
sucks here's why it sucks folks a
politician who is running never wants to
stifle
the boat in their party's primary like
why would you say
hey don't go vote there's no reason to
bother the scanners aren't even working
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
like she knows she's going to lose right
she's going to lose this race no i'm not
going to get it i mean this is very much
out of the trump playbook you you so
doubt you say hey this thing is in
question people then say
hey oh you know they they cause uh maybe
they cause an issue right they they kind
of i don't know maybe they cause a
little bit of a riot at local uh you
know um
polling places where they say the
scanner's not working even though it
literally is and they're like sir uh you
just have to turn it this way as it's
directed or someone's like ma'am this is
a wendy's we don't take actual ballots
here this is if you want to order a
frosting location right exactly
so i wouldn't be surprised if somebody
shows up causing iraqis and not they
have not even voted yet or maybe they
have voted and they went to another
location to try and vote because that's
very much the republican way as we've
just learned in michigan even more voter
fraud of course from the republican
party right right well i i mean
this
and i and i i don't want to say this too
far out loud um because this is a good
sign that they're already willing to
torch their primary races with this
election fraud and we should not
discourage this you know everyone always
talks about uh suppression the
republicans suppress the vote their
self-suppressing here is what they're
doing
and when
when
when your political enemy when the
fascists are digging their grave
you do not take the shovel out of their
hands you let them dig that in fact you
might just give them like a backhoe like
here you go here's a backhoe dig that
political grave because i believe what
candace taylor might be doing here
because you gotta remember she's in the
governor's race right right
so the governor's race is probably gonna
be brian kemp which means that trump is
going to lose
because he lost out on endorsing this
nut bag and david perdue the one who he
did endorse is going to lose to the
incumbent brian kemp
who trump hates because
kemp wouldn't actually just declare him
the winner right of the of the georgia
2020 election the presidential election
which brian kemp does not have the
authority to do but anyways
stacey abrams is going to be running
against whoever the republican nominee
is right now candace taylor this
whack-a-doo starts running all over the
state and can raise money from her
marjorie taylor green type supporters
and go all over the state showing doubt
not with democrats right not with not
with reasonable voters
well we're talking about the loonies of
the loonies of the loonies because if
you remember in georgia just a few years
ago
there was a runoff election that both
republicans were supposed to win and
donald trump went to that state and said
it's rigged it's rigged it's rigged no
matter what you do the democrats are
going to win and what happened what
happened both democrats won that runoff
race that they really weren't supposed
to win if you go back and you look at
the general election numbers they
weren't supposed to win that race
but boy did stacey abrams get out there
and work hard on that race and boy did
the voters come to the polls because we
knew the stakes we knew the stakes if
those two races went south mitch
mcconnell would be this would be the
the majority leader in the senate which
would have stalled any kind of work and
any kind of progress in this but also i
think the biggest point is boy did we
need those seats right like what we have
accomplished with a split 50 50 if we
did not have that i think it would be
you know
well that's a good point but also we're
not exactly a 50 50. how sparks likes to
bring this up i know we have sparklers
um
hal sparks fans that come watch our show
so shout out to hal here hal actually
says um he kind of frames it up is it's
a 48-52
a with a tiebreaker because two of the
democrats quote unquote
caucus that with the democrats are
independents we have angus king and we
have bernie sanders they're not
democrats they caucus with the democrats
they caucus to form
that majority that we have with kamala
harris as the tiebreaker vote
so we're barely there in the first place
right that's why pennsylvania's so
important ohio's so important these
races this race in florida so important
and ron desantis is doing everything he
can um everything he can to make sure
that that race in florida does not go
south on him he definitely does not want
a democratic senator because then he'll
have to actually go to a democratic
senator to maybe get some things from
washington i don't know when this
hurricane season starts because apparent
to noah this morning it is going to be
uh something and of course and of course
we'll have ron desantis and others
saying you know thoughts and prayers but
mostly
that government money am i right you
guys want to send that help down here
well i mean which is the same which is
the same effect of what happened in
texas what you had uh you know uh greg
abbott yep ted cruz saying uh actually
why should we help new jersey and new
york after these uh the hurricane season
and then and then within months you know
i think or maybe about a year or so the
next hurricane that comes through texas
still like oh please please please
please please give us money and it's
like okay do you not understand
the complete flip-flop the hypocrisy of
not wanting to aid another state who
goes through a natural disaster and then
as soon as it hits
your front yard that you're like oh uh
actually uh we we actually need your
help you know right well i mean ron
desantis has done the same thing with
the stimulus or the the covid stimulus
money right oh he was against it it's
socialism and he runs around the state
giving out big ass checks like he's in
some kind of golf tournament and like
he's like yeah i i did this it was me
that gave you this money right right or
even yeah i mean the infrastructure as
well he's like you know i don't support
this these bills i don't support this
and then as soon as any funding that
comes to the just the the general united
states and there's obviously stuff that
is allocated to florida he goes look at
what i did right even though that the
republican party has been very much
against any sort of uh aid that would
just help the foundation of the country
they say no no no no no you can't you
can't help americans you can't help
americans that is not the the gqp way
you definitely have to [ __ ] all over
america yes yeah yeah it was definitely
what you should do smear it
and then ask for the same thing right
and and the reason why is because the
founding fathers you know
they can't they wanted this and we're
going to see this from this candidate uh
candace taylor here um this is a video
that patriot takes uh put out on twitter
is this the one where she's talking
about
um yes yes so pager takes says here
georgia republican gubernatorial
candidate candace taylor said our
founding fathers came to destroy
american indians
homes and their land
to secure our right to worship jesus
jesus freely so she actually she
actually uses jesus's name as a
justification for genocide of indigenous
people in this game what i want to know
though is like when you use the term
founding fathers right
[Music]
she is she talking about like
the the people who were involved in
writing the constitution and like those
founding fathers because if that's the
case it's like
look there was a bit of time before
these founding fathers ever born so it's
like i guess before that sperm hit that
egg
they already had that thought oh yeah
absolutely well gabe gabe listen the
secular founding fathers were definitely
christian and definitely wanted this to
be a christian nation right so they get
history all turned around they right
right
they see the puritans as like oh they're
the founding fathers like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about right right right
right we're dead and gone long after
long
long before
we ever had the constitution you
listen we're leaving this royal family
and right and the religious background
that they have because we want to get
away
to do it to another i mean
well the other thing too is the other
thing too is they want to come over you
know the puritans came over like we're
going to have us some george
washington's and thomas jefferson's one
of these days they're like and i'm going
to have a kid who's going to be the
president but when he's a kid he's going
to chop down that cherry but then he
can't tell a lie right exactly because
that's all true
all of it all of it that you just said
that's all real history let's listen to
candace taylor
educate us
on
why maybe we actually should have crt i
don't know the first amendment right
i wasn't prepared my sound dissolved
come on i sent you the video and you're
jumping in the middle of the video now
people who are watching are like i don't
know what the context is where am i
okay here we go here we go
the first amendment right which is our
right to worship jesus freely that's why
we have a country that's why we have
georgia that's why we had our founder
fathers come over here and destroy
american indians homes in their land
they took it look at what they went to
native americans for sacrifice for us to
have the freedom we have today what the
[ __ ] is she talk okay so she's saying
she's saying thank god we we committed
genocide on indigenous people that way
we can worship our god she's like [ __ ]
their god [ __ ] well she also she also
well one she said first said american
indian so it's like even before anyone
from india came to america and had a
family and was like oh i'm an american
indian right she she has that group and
then she brings in native indians right
which is like
look you know this indigenous people
were here before you that is clearly not
what the founding fathers want but the
fact they're using religious text or
just like
that religious kind of facade as an
excuse of like genocide's cool because
founding fathers
yeah the white dudes killed indigenous
people so we could have us some jesus
and jesus is okay with that right and
which is which again i think i said it
last week where i was talking about like
old testament new testament maybe this
week before i forget because time right
now has no meaning and the past is the
president the president is the future i
don't know what's going on but what i
remember saying on the show was that
these christians remember christianity
was was was created
you know from jesus right you follow
christ
you are a christian
now before christ right we're talking
old testament stuff you've got this
uh
omnipotent god right he's like i'm all
powerful i don't give you uh any second
chances i smote you at the [ __ ]
second that you doubt
my my just like my presence and my power
now all these christians reference old
testament god wait wait which is like
what let's
questions because the way that i think
about this is like this
old testament god was like god who
didn't have a kid right because
essentially that's true right he didn't
have a kid so he was like wild and
[ __ ] partying and doing whatever he
wants debauchery he's like yeah i'm
[ __ ] torching that [ __ ] i'm making
that [ __ ] i'm throwing these bottles
wherever i want no
no discretion for anything and then the
new testament comes along and he has a
kid he's like oh [ __ ] man i gotta grow
up and i've gotta i've got a child
that's kind of what you said i it is it
is okay because joseph you know joseph
when he was like 30 something mary was
like 12 and it was like he was like
listen i didn't touch that girl i did
not i did not touch
are you saying that that joseph is a god
cuck is that what i think he is very
much a god okay okay but in this in this
world christians love to quote or use
old testament god the the one who was
[ __ ] thrashing the place in trash in
hotel rooms and all that stuff
but really they live under the
christianity which is new testament god
which is like oh i've got like i'm gonna
i'm gonna take a beat here guys i'm
gonna really assess the situation and
then decide what i'm gonna do
because i've brought this new life into
this world um so they they say they're
christians but they live in an old
testament kind of world you know
well i you know where genocide was okay
right yeah yeah yeah that was that was
that was like
that was like a normal tuesday for guys
you know taco genocide tuesday right
like he's like you smoke you smoke you
smote right you know right and and you
know you know i mean why not cheer why
not cheer genocide so that jesus can
have his religious freedom in this
country this is really [ __ ] dumb this
is really [ __ ] stupid and it is no
wonder that this whack-a-doo is not
going to win anything in georgia the
best part though is the best part is her
message needs to be trumpeted to the
people who would go vote for her that is
very important folks that is very very
important and democrats have done this
[ __ ] for years where they're like oh we
can't win anyways we can't win in texas
who gives a [ __ ] don't go vote if you
can't win don't get off the couch no go
[ __ ] vote like right now is the time
to go vote even if we [ __ ] lose you
have to vote you have to prove to them i
mean wasn't it in the polls wasn't it
ellen wood who told people
not to go vote right in georgia yes he
said
don't go vote it's not worth it right
because it's rigged it's going to be
it's already rigged
already the outcome is already
determined which i'm like hey do it
again if you want i don't [ __ ] care
if you guys want to say the election's
rigged obviously you're going to find
out that you know uh 9 out of 10 10 out
of 10 times it's the republican party
because i have yet to find an actual
case of a democrat voting that has
committed voter fraud
you know everything has been people in
republican counties and republican
voters texas
michigan
the [ __ ] villages in florida yeah
particularly particularly south florida
it's very concentrated yeah yeah it's
weird it's weird why it's always florida
and it always seems to be for one
mussolini jesus yeah that's the
committing you got like
you got the real mussolini jesus and
then you got the wannabe mussolini
genius jesus like the clone like
he's like slowly hoping that he will
become the new mussolini jesus you know
you're you're talking about ron desantis
yeah yeah i'm talking about ronda santos
he is
slowly in his metamorphosis
shifting into
you know don uh donald uh trump um
right right hand face
the next is gonna be the lean right the
how he does the the uh dr evil kind of
forward lean you know oh okay so so he's
gonna have to he's gonna have to really
get a special type of shoe to get the
the lean yeah yeah i mean if anyone's
seen uh
uh austin powers
his lean
is very akin and i'll pull the phone a
second it's very akin to when austin
powers sat on many me shoulders and they
had the trench coat on and they were
leaning like you know all the way
forward that is very much the trump way
if you look at the photos of him press
conferences he's just forward leaning
you know like he's got like somehow
he's trying to do like michael jackson
where he's like going all the way down
and coming back up but he's just
perpetually in this like kind of 20
degree tilt the whole time right well
you know the lean a lot of people
a kindle lean to that he's got dementia
or something and some something to do
with dementia but here's the thing he
he's a
[ __ ] snowflake and he can't stand
when someone's taller than him so he
wears lifts that keep his heels out of
his loafers
so the guy has to lean forward because
he's get i mean he's standing on a wedge
right right and the other thing is about
the ramp everyone said he couldn't
handle the ramp well the reason why he
can't walk down a ramp if you think
about like if you were walking with a
pair of shoes where your heels couldn't
stay in them you do this little waddle
penguin type walk to keep your toes in
the shoes because you were wedged in
with lifts and that's why the guy does
it any i mean you know i want to claim
that he's lost his [ __ ] mind which he
has a long time ago but the thing is
he's got lifts in his shoes he's got and
they're probably two or three inch lifts
you know because he just can't stand
being shorter than somebody right he
just can't stand it
no pun intended well he can't i mean he
can't stand a lot of things right
because if you look at comparison like
the bar is pretty low
if there's anyone that is better than
him which is most likely all people he
takes it personally and is like you know
when he goes in for a handshake he's
like i gotta [ __ ] thrust you know
that's why the whole and it's funny
enough the photo i just sent you which
is of his lean when he's shaking hands
with trudeau if you watch video clips of
trudeau going in for handshakes with
trump he's learned
what trump would do when he did get big
handshake which is like he would pull in
and pull the person in and trudeau
now counteracts and pulls him in as a
response so this is a comparison of what
i was talking about which is uh awesome
powers on the on the shoulders of many
me giving the forward lean is the same
one that trump does
in any moment in time during his
presidency and still now
um and again if you look here if you
look here at the two men
trudeau is
damn near taller than trump but without
the lifts he would be a lot taller right
exactly than trump yeah and that and and
and trudeau is definitely not wearing
lifts here yeah because you know he he
probably has an ego but he doesn't wear
his ego in his shoes right right like
and yeah and one of the things i said
this before is um as you mentioned
dementia like i think uh donald trump
actually suffers from
neurosyphilis
and it's the same thing okay so explain
that explain it so yeah it's kind of
what what um is what el capone yeah yeah
and pretty much died from what what
movie is it i think um
tom hardy plays capone in a movie where
he's at the stage in his life where he's
lost his his [ __ ] mind and he's he's
suffering from this yeah it's called
it's called capone is it well that's
that that would be appropriate it makes
sense that would make sense right but
yeah it's it's one of those things like
i don't it was like 2018 you know and i
was like hey you know i'm not saying he
has neurosyphilis
but
if he does have some neurological thing
i wouldn't be surprised if he got
syphilis and then
uh was untreated
and then you know did treat it but at
this point it's kind of taken its course
and it has you know infected his brain
so
you know i i'm not i i don't look i'm no
doctor i only you know i just grew up
around a mom who was in the medical
field and this is my non-medical related
diagnosis breaking news breaking news it
is official we can announce that donald
trump has neurosyphilis speaking of uh
people that remind you a neural syphilis
you posted this um what what i'm trying
to get my transitions yeah you're good
the transitions baby the transitions the
transitions are badass here on the tony
michael's podcast you will not find a
transition that is better doesn't this
guy
remind you of like a neurosyphilis in
human form though i mean oh like if
neurosyphilis became a human form if
this guy might be in
if it just again morphed into a body
into an animate object it was like boom
greg log this is this is neural
civilization this whole thing is wild i
watched this uh sermon from sunday you
watched the whole thing no i didn't
watch oh okay
holy [ __ ] into about an hour because
like the first hour they're playing
music and doing all those stuff and he
kind of oh sorry they're actually doing
the god thing yeah yeah it's like a
couple before greg goes out on his
tangent right exactly and it's not just
he doesn't just go after uh
uh kenneth copeland in the situation he
goes after other people as well just
kenneth copeland is the like primary
target that is in his island
he's like i got a target on ken copeland
whether it's out of envy jealousy or he
actually does believe kenneth copeland
is a demon and
oakland is a demon i will agree yeah i
agree with gregor listen last last week
uh i believe it was we played a yeah a
video of greg locke talking about how he
was gonna you know take the government
by force and democrats or demons and
democrats can't be christians and all
this nonsense on and on and on it went
now apparently over the weekend uh some
tick tockers got a hold of this and they
decided to
mass report greg locke to the irs about
his 501c3 i
i'm going to go on a limb here i don't
think he actually dissolved his 5013c
well i mean if you're saying that greg
locke is a liar then i would definitely
agree everyone's like oh my god he's not
exempt anymore and i'm gonna say
[ __ ]
don't believe it right i don't i don't
know if i don't know if he dissolved it
he ha they were like you're not one
anymore
or or he's in the process of doing it
but but either way we're gonna we're
gonna look at this video because i find
it very interesting
a couple different things about griglock
because if you go out on the interwebs
youtube especially and you go to some of
these right-wing pastors who are who are
i mean vehemently
uh
anti-lgbtq they
they [ __ ] say some hateful ass [ __ ] i
mean just hateful bigoted [ __ ] they do
but they're christians black but they do
not like great glock they have turned on
greg yeah because greg locke puts them
at risk here with some of the [ __ ] he
says
because he really does borderline on
threats he really does uh put a 501c3
in jeopardy and that's their entire
existence right like their entire
existence to spread their hatred and
bigotry is to do it tax-free right yeah
we'd do it tax-free we don't get taxed
now greg lock in this video you're gonna
see how he denounces
a 501 c3 which is kind of funny and i'll
tell you why but you tweeted jesus i
think it's safe to say manga hate
preacher greg locke does not
like televangelist grifter kenneth
copeland which if anyone knows kenny
copeland out there you know he's a woo
he's a whack dude he's the one that was
remember uh covet he was
what what was the video you gotta [ __ ]
yeah yeah i'll find the video
he blows like spitting blowing it away
or some [ __ ] some weird ass [ __ ] like
stop spitting on me you kobe spreader
but uh um in this video that we're gonna
watch of greg locke here which is uh
i think a couple minutes long kenneth
copeland is a demon and he knows it is
what greg locke said so let's i'm
telling you there are more demons in
evangelical pulpits
than there are hookers in the red light
district of la right now they everywhere
we don't have a red light district here
in la i just want to preface that for
people
we do not have one
that i know of at least
see this is this is the [ __ ] they do
this is projection
greg lock has definitely 100 percent
ordered had sex with and probably done
some
really really gross [ __ ] to prostitutes
sex work is work people we should not
demonize these people we should not make
these people unsafe and griglock is
making the
these people who do this job very unsafe
and i'm sure he has done some vile [ __ ]
to people who are in that field of work
and greg locke definitely has been in
the quote unquote red light district
wherever the [ __ ] he thinks that yeah
and he has ordered prostitutes and had
sex with prostitutes this is projection
uh let's continue with the projection
here and nobody wants to expose them and
i get people they'll fight me i can't
believe you named that name i can't
believe you still gullible enough to
follow that fool if i got to run around
with pedophiles if i got to run around
with money grubbing nonsense i ain't
messing with her um more projection yeah
i mean this is this is really
i mean what the [ __ ] does this have to
do with preaching a sermon from the
bible i don't know he went on a comp he
went on a tangent because the the the
sermon it was given it was like do not
follow false prophets and then he wanted
this whole thing about he's like listen
i'm gonna say some stuff that you don't
like and i'm okay with losing friends
but what i will tell you
is kenneth copeland
is a grifter he's a demon he's a dead
he's a false prophet he goes he is a
greater he is a yeah yeah he is well he
doesn't actually say grifter in here i
just said grifter because that's what he
is right well he calls him false prophet
he calls him a demon and then he goes
into the whole masonic
demonic cult thing it's a whole it's
it's crazy
so so so you cut this down right yeah
you went in and you you cut this clip
down to what what we have here yeah this
is like how long was this diatribe that
he uh i want to say that the actual
rant he went on was like maybe 15 to 20
minutes so this is the juicy stuff this
is the juicy stuff there's other people
he mentions in there like just like a
couple things where he's like don't be
surprised if you see this person get
arrested and i was like i don't know if
anyone's gonna really know who these
people are so i just focused on kenneth
copeland and boy did he have a lot to
say about kenneth copeland well let's
get to it
so i'm gonna hurt some of you feelings
right now i'm gonna hurt a lot of my
friends feelings right now kenneth
copeland is a heretic you hear me
kenneth copeland is the number one
christian heretic in america
he hates him some [ __ ] kenneth
copeland yeah yeah i he [ __ ] he he
has turned on kenneth copeland here my
guess is it's because kenneth copeland
definitely won't uh throw down any kind
of funds
to probably maybe maybe they don't go to
the same you know sex orgy parties i
don't i you know those cocaine sex
orgies are kind of exclusive i hear
so you may have to have an invitation
and greg locke has lost his i guess
right he would know a bible if he bit
him in the butt in the middle of the
road well kenny copeland ain't what what
does that mean what does that mean i
don't know you know i think about i
thought about that all all yesterday as
i was cutting this clip in the morning i
was like
what does he mean
bite him in the butt in the middle of
the road right what is the bible doing
in the middle of the road in the first
right like i don't i don't know it just
seems like a weird combination to be
like the bible like oh sir what happened
to you why are you in the emergency room
well uh it's kind of a crazy story but
you just just hear me out okay there was
a bible and i was in the middle of the
road i was just crossing the road you
know it was i was doing nothing wrong
and then this bible attacked me and it
bit me in the butt it jumped up and bit
me they're like what are you what are
you what are you talking about sir what
the hell is going on and they're like
maybe you know what let's do a psych
eval real quick let's just figure out
make sure you're okay do do you have
family or anyone related that is like in
the area that could come pick you up and
he's like i'm telling you a bible beat
me in the butt in the middle of the road
like
this is insane
remember this guy is is doing his sermon
in tennessee right it's in tennessee uh
i don't know usually he's in a circus
tent like well literally yeah he's in a
circus tent
uh
this is the circus folks that you're
watching here literally for the show
baby welcome to the clown
whoosh let's let's keep going while
you're looking it up there paying none
of my bills and i wouldn't take none of
his blood money no how false profits are
false profits
so this is this is where i tweeted
because he said i wouldn't take any of
his money anyhow and from the pod
account i tweeted false profits like
money profits right because you cut it
as if he was talking about money and
then false profits false profits because
you know if these churches are going to
continue this this this political
activity i believe it is false profits
and they should be taxed um which is
what we're going to get to here which is
kind of the juice here of why greg locke
kind of does this rant
because these pastors i believe are
turning on him because he's kind of
exposing that they're not 501 c3s he's
like
greg locke is saying the quiet part out
loud right like like donald trump did
for all the fascists in this country
that they're not actually 500 they're
not charitable organizations right it's
for-profit organizations and
greg locke ministries llc
uh i don't know if that's the actual
company that has the the status the tax
exempt status or if it's something else
i wouldn't be surprised if it's
something owns another thing owns
another thing and it's buried within
something deep where he has tax exempt
status but it's located in wilson county
tennessee it's a religious institution
according to google you know we should
open up our own religious institutions i
think we should
i mean
why not it's uh the same thing uh
that john's uh no not jon stewart it was
um
yeah stephen colbert did the uh
he he opened
well maybe we should do that too we
could have a we could have a religious
organization and we could have a super
pac we could do that
john oliver opened uh he started uh
there was a whole
he started a whole thing on like how a
taxis and status are given to religious
organization and he started one it's
actually a pretty good segment it's from
a few years ago
maybe maybe we'll have to check that out
let's listen to what greg locke says
about a 501c3 and the irs and the fbi
too he even invokes the fbi here quit
sending the money and buying their books
kenneth copeland is a demon and he knows
it i don't know how much money he's got
he's got a lot and he got it off of
naive christians that ought to tie it to
the local church and quit sending the
money i'm just letting it settle in on
you for it i know i got some friends
right now they're like
he's committing pastoral suicide huh
it's not just friends that are like that
greg it's not just your friends like
everyone everybody watching this is like
he's over here like fanning he's like
sorry i just put out a big ass fart of
pastoral scenes oh my god this this
[ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy whoosh
oh no i'm not i wouldn't preach for him
if he begged me tomorrow on his knees
and offered me a million
i am not meh he was he gonna say
something about kenneth copeland being
on his knees i almost thought
he was he said something about a million
bucks then he went to save he's going to
say something yeah and then he rebounded
he's like nope can't say that yeah i
can't say that can't say that he's like
i'll say all this other stuff about
kenneth copeland right on his knees
right insane bro
with false prophets you know why kenneth
copeland won't sue me because he knows i
got the receipts he's a false prophet
kenny copeland should be under the jail
you would be shocked if you knew what's
going on behind closed doors in these
pastors offices
wait a second if this guy knows all this
stuff right if if greg locke really
knows all this stuff
isn't he culpable into knowing all this
stuff i mean really he says
i don't doubt that there's a lot of [ __ ]
right no for sure for sure i don't know
how he knows if somebody told him he was
the cuck in the corner or he was
watching through a little peephole right
inside of uh inside of a painting you
know like a [ __ ] scooby-doo villain
right
but if he knows these things then he is
a witness or he's complicit in a crime
that was committed in these offices of
different pastors what the [ __ ] does
that mean i mean really this has the
stench
the stench of cocaine sex orgies madison
cousins stuff oh this is right yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah this definitely has
cousin humping written all over and it
is you know it is greg locke and it is
kenneth copeland so you know i don't
know if they're related but maybe that
hey i don't know you wouldn't be like oh
my goodness
i don't care have i not explained to you
i don't care what you think about what
i'm saying because the bible says beware
of false prophets so apparently they're
around the only thing they get me on
being a false prophet is i call out
democrats and preach against demons well
if that makes me a false prophet then
lie did i
die
i was really hoping you're gonna drop
that mic
really honestly this is a circus i want
to see more juggling really honestly i
mean if he brought out clowns to juggle
like bowling pins or something right i
mean
look i would watch every week greg if
you had the clowns come out and do some
juggling and [ __ ] maybe like like the
the fire breathers oh yeah yeah
that might be a little too demonic you
know you know it's like ooh we got
satan's satan's cult up here you know i
don't well well he's going to talk about
satan's cult here in just a second
listen to this i dare i dare i dare
kenneth copeland to take me to court and
sue me for what i'm about to say he is a
33rd degree mason why why would kenneth
copeland take him to court because he's
a mason i don't know what does that have
to do with it that might be what he's
about to say in a moment oh let's see he
is in the masonic satanic cult
there you go oh my god like this totally
reminds me of the video that we watched
several weeks ago of alex jones he's
like god he's gonna
come and get you you demons the
vengeance of god
these people always have this same
little dick satanic energy right and
then greg glock goes from
the degree
33 degrees and down a temple and now
back to the sermon
like that's that's exactly what is
happening here it is very much alex
jones what is this [ __ ] going to be a
spectator at the great white throne
judgment when god looks at kenneth
copeland and says depart from me ye that
work iniquity you going to hell for all
of eternity cause you a lion sorry low
down good for nothing sack of false
prophecy we'll wait till we got all the
uh the cards on the table and we'll just
have us a big old national press
conference and we'll just call them all
what they are
okay right and now and now back to the
sermon yeah and now back to
communion right back to jesus back to
jesus jesus because this is exactly what
jesus would do what in the [ __ ] so so uh
i i was getting this clip confused with
another one that came out i think
tennessee tennessee holler had the other
one that i was thinking of yeah talking
about the irs because that was that was
a popular one here's what here's what
i'll say on this everyone else was
focused on the tax-exempt status hey
he's him saying that he's done he's not
tax-exempt he could you know tell the
irs to come after him whatever else
right because that was the tick-tock
thing right right
yeah that was a tick-tock and that was
the video that was getting around and
that's what everyone was talking about
right and until i actually see paperwork
that proves it i won't believe it would
you believe anything that [ __ ]
did you just see that video yeah i mean
i don't know i know do you believe
anything but everyone everyone was
focused on the tax thing and i was like
you guys are bearing the lead here the
real lead
is the infighting within these uh mega
church grifting
type personalities they don't [ __ ] on
each other but don't you think though
that the reason why they're abandoning
greg locke is because what we said
earlier he's saying the quiet part out
loud here oh yeah he's basically saying
we're not we are political organizations
we are not we are not charitable
organizations right exactly he's making
the case right for why they should not
have this tax exempt status right and
they're all pissed off because they're
like listen i need another g5 on the
runway
so i can just fly it in unison with my
other one you know will you shut the
[ __ ] up for a minute
quite
we'll buy you a church if you shut the
[ __ ] up you know right well i mean and
and maybe a good analogy greg locke is
donald trump and if that is true kenneth
copeland is mitch mcconnell right like
stop cut it out cut out the [ __ ]
because we see that in the um apparently
the the election fraud in michigan which
we might get to today but i i want to i
want to play this clip by tennessee
holler here of greg lock this is the
same this is the same sermon this is may
22nd right this is this is just a
different part of that this is from
before okay this happened before so so
the craziness that we just seen happened
after he said this [ __ ] okay let's let's
listen just in case some of y'all been
reading the newspaper do you think we're
crazy nobody's forcing you to be here
today
drag him out right i love the piano in
the background yeah yeah like that
there's someone in there
there's someone in this church that
spoke out you know he's like ah he said
something and then here we go greg locks
saying drag him
out well i just said he was donald trump
asked but let's listen do you think
we're crazy nobody's forcing you to be
here today
drag him out right now in jesus name
drag both of them drag him out in jesus
name
hey can you kill that guy but in jesus
name
listen jesus i want you to jesus i want
you to pick him up and open the door
with his head oh my god but i want to
point out that that is probably the most
dangerous part when you use in jesus
name as an excuse or or the way in which
you
rationalize or try to justify and act
that's like go commit genocide in jesus
name go kill this person what the
[ __ ] what's her name candace right
exactly dumb [ __ ] that's running for
governor it's like look go rape this
person in jesus name like that is what
he's saying it's all good if you do it
in jesus name
that is why religion
is a [ __ ]
it is it is rotten to its core
it creates hostility it has created wars
have we seen over time
and it it brings out the worst in people
maybe maybe religion maybe religion
helps you to kind of find your way
that's totally fine but when you use it
as a justification for acting out
something against a group of people or
just an individual that is when you know
that religion is a very very bad thing
well american evangelicalism especially
the great glock kenneth copeland style
is very [ __ ] dangerous and very gross
but let's listen to his justification of
his irs status because it it really it's
again it's very trumpy and it's
double-sided here listen right mountain
jesus name get out in jesus name you
demon you do it while i'm preaching i'll
take this microphone and bust you into
mouth with the name of god
i should have kept playing it because
yeah i'm not even to the good part here
he's talking about busting someone in
the mouth the name in the name of god
he's like listen i'm gonna physically
assault this person in the name of god
you're all witnesses but god was the one
who gave me the power
to bestow this mic upside this person's
head so
none of y'all better change on me this
is the projection game he thinks he and
this is why this is why greg locke is
losing his mind this is why people like
kenneth copeland and these other pastors
are abandoning this fool because
as as much as he projects that he knows
the skeletons in their closets what he's
saying in that last clip we were
watching they know the skeletons in his
closet oh yeah they know the skeleton oh
it's a two-way street that's right
way down and this whole i use god my god
is my excuse to do all my sins like this
is this is [ __ ] ridiculous this is
total
full-on projection and you're going to
see it with the irs thing here we ain't
playing your stupid democrat games and
so father we need to be released in the
spirit of giving we might need to give a
little bit so we increase security
around here though he didn't go get no
better it's going to get worse people to
make up our mind who's is he praying
here yes he's praying because there's a
person behind him that's leaning their
head on his back and he's got his eyes
closed he's praying he's praying
like prayers oh my god
yeah no it's a god
in this fight saying that i called last
week to take up arms against the
government if they heard that they're
smoking crack apparently they didn't pay
attention you got hating communist
america you'll find out where the
insurrection is because we ain't playing
your garbage we ain't playing your mess
so that wasn't at all what i see no they
don't care what you say
they only care what it sounds like you
say so that they can make you say what
they want you to say so they can
inviscerate you that's why you say what
you say how you say it so that we'll say
that you said it that way yeah like
literally that's exactly that's right
that's right greg locke yeah that's why
you're saying it the way that you're
saying it i mean it's very trump-like
right he's like i never said that liz i
said a thing that you think i said but i
didn't really say the thing that you
think i said but really what i said was
different from that thing that you said
that i think that i said and i don't
actually know what i'm saying right now
[Laughter]
ah these [ __ ] these [ __ ] the bible
says that we'll take it by force
everybody mad because i said that in
this day and age you can't be a
christian and vote democrat which by the
way you can't okay so i still believe
that because everybody's like oh what we
need to do is take away their tax exempt
stash so he's he's saying what everyone
is thinking here even even like kenneth
copeland and all his other pastor
buddies they're thinking the same thing
like yeah strip this guy of his 501c3
and concentrate and focus on greg locke
do not see
don't focus over here
to what magic we're trying to pull
and definitely focus on greg lock and
and again the story is
that tick tockers really took the clip
last week of griglock and started
circulating around to get people maybe
encourage people to report him to the
irs i got an attorney and i dissolved
our stinking 501c3
in this church because the government
ain't gonna tell me what i can and what
i can't say so irs
we don't need your stupid tax exempt
status
now he understands that even if he
doesn't have a tax-exempt status
he still
has to deal with um what's that agency
that um
the irs he still understands he
understands like it doesn't matter like
the irs is like we don't give a [ __ ] if
you're exempt or not right we just need
to know if you are and if we need to
collect taxes from your dumb ass right
they don't give a [ __ ] about your tax
exempt status really other than the fact
of rather you are you are not a 501c3
and you should be classified that way
and if they should tax you or not right
this is craziness announce
501c3 communism in this church
the fbi and everybody we've been turned
into can eat my dirty socks on live tv
i'm sick of all these limp-wristed false
prophet pastors
siding with the democrats no wonder
these penny-wearing pastors close their
church down during coven okay this is
very important this is a very important
part of this clip
he says these panty wearing pastors it
almost feels like to me gabe it almost
feels like to me that at these uh
cocaine field sex orgies
um
and we might have seen we might have
seen a picture of madison kawthorne who
claimed he was invited to these type of
orders right right right wearing women's
underwear women's lingerie
so i don't maybe greg lock is trying to
tell us something here i mean he's also
saying he's also saying that all these
places close their doors meanwhile greg
lock's like i don't even have doors to
close i'm going to paint guys i'm going
to take you to the middle of the [ __ ]
field in tennessee
can we just can we collapse it like what
can we just like shut it down like bring
it bring it down i don't have doors guys
how do i close these doors even if i
wanted to i couldn't close these doors
whoosh
whoosh this [ __ ] guy let's yeah wait
the other thing that he says is that
um that 501 c3s are communism so
basically what greg locke is saying is
all the 501c3 he's been doing all these
years
all that's been communism yeah all that
money that he has saved to accumulate
his wealth to build out a bigger and
bigger tent right he now says well that
was communism that was socialism
you guys
i should not have taken that if that's
the case i want him to return all that
money that's right it's demonic democrat
type stuff to have 501 i mean it's also
like when you have a church and they're
like hey everyone put money into the
collections basket that's a kind of a
mini socialism right you all contributed
and gave money and paid to this group
right for them to build out and make it
better so that you could use the next
time around easy do not let greg lock
know that that that the
that jesus who is actually a brown man
would be a socialist don't
be careful i don't remember i do not
remember jesus actually taking money so
there's also that as well you know yeah
well let's let's finish what this
wackadoo has to say
bunch of sissies let their wife run the
show i revoke our 501c3 status and irs
we don't give two flips what you think
about it we gonna take away his
five-on-one oh yeah we gave it up it's
stupid so you and all your compromising
communism
501c3 can get out
when tyranny becomes law rebellion
becomes biblical i'm calling for
christians to stop being wimps is what
i'm calling for it's amazing what i'm
preaching on today by the way beware of
false prophets which come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly they're
ravening wolves
huh that seemed like a little bit of
projection there yeah a lot
a lot of projections yeah
a lot of projection with these guys uh
it looks like sorry so i know it looks
like we're having issues with yeah i i i
i noticed that right before we came on
with youtube and um so i got to fix that
after the show i didn't have time to fix
it before so we will have it tomorrow
no worries no worries i do want to play
the uh you sent me this video because we
because we did we did allow greg lock to
slander um yeah i mean you have to give
the opportunity for kenneth copeland to
defend himself right which i'm still
waiting on we'll see if that actually
comes out right well let's let's see um
if kenneth copeland actually is a demon
deer let's see if there's proof of this
let's see if greg glock is right
covet 19 yeah
on
you are destroyed forever
and you will never be back
thank you our god thank you
let it happen
cause it to happen
what what the [ __ ] is this i mean like
we've seen this before but i mean i've
rewatched this and i'm like what in the
[ __ ] is this
you know what's weird is you know why i
mean there's a lot of things that are
yeah okay we're in
here we are in an empty
uh church right now and i say that very
loosely church right right uh
i don't know if like i can't tell if
kenneth copeland actually believes in
covid right or
or they were forced to do this right
right but the group is
kind of six feet apart from each other
right you know they're being separate
they don't have people in there he
believes in covid enough
where he thinks that covet can be cured
by a
a blow
by spitting on people he's spitting on
people like [ __ ] the camera guy there's
like oh man good thing i'm like 200 feet
away jesus christ
oh [ __ ] you know and um
kenneth i i don't normally agree with
greg locke on anything like
on anything but i really do gabe have to
agree with greg lock on this
i think that kenneth copeland really is
a [ __ ] demon oh
he is for sure a demon
oh crazy ass
oh crazy ass [ __ ] why do we have to why
do we have to go through this um so
let's get back to the tweety tweets and
trendy trends let's let's get off the
religion here for a minute and let's get
to let's get off our religious pulpit
okay
take a step down you know maybe
here for a second um you've seen the
news of uh kissinger um
being putin sycophants here saying that
russia must give away part of their
territory which they already had they
already have they've already given away
the crimean this is already a thing this
is like oh well if you want to stop
putin just capitulate to him yeah if you
want to stop a murderous dictator
capitulate to him which most people are
telling him i think he'd [ __ ] himself i
thought henry kissinger was already dead
just gonna be honest well i thought he
was already dead and then he showed up
he showed up in the trends and i was
like this guy's still alive
what man i thought he was dead like when
i was in junior high a long time ago i
thought this [ __ ] was dead he
was like he was like 100 years old
in the black and white era when he was
on tv in the black and white air wasn't
he it is amazing how many years blood
money can buy you you know right i guess
so i guess so ricky gervais the comedian
is in the news uh did you watch did you
watch the clip of the jokes that he's
making about trans people did you watch
the clip i have not watched a clip i
only know the recent uh
backlash but that was for dave
chappelle's transphobic joke so i
haven't seen anything about this yet
right so dave chappelle we all know that
netflix is also caught hell for for
amplifying dave chappelle uh ricky
gervais has a new comedy special and i
forget exactly what it's called i guess
it doesn't i think it's super super
nature maybe is what what it's called um
and it's on netflix obviously
uh because netflix is catching hell too
but ricky gervais is really catching him
here the thing that's interesting to me
is
how the right-wing christians like some
of the people that we were just watching
how they are going to
really form up that they're forming an
alliance with someone like ricky gervais
who absolutely is not an ally
of that community it's going to be
really weird to watch this online unfold
this is kind of like it's kind of like
going gonna happen like the will smith
chris rock incident and i know it has
much more social issues involved with
the trans community um i went and
listened to part of the jokes i haven't
watched the whole special so i can't
speak on it i can only speak on a few of
the jokes that i watch him tell
and they are pretty insensitive yeah
they are not as direct as dave
chappelle's jokes towards uh specific
people um they are a little more ham
handed i guess you would say but for
ricky gervais to take aim
at a marginalized community
in his special with netflix
i think is intentional
in that he wants hit he wants to trend
for this
um netflix wants to trend for this
because they want us to go all walk to
go watch this yeah right is is kind of
my opinion here i think i think um
netflix is now baiting some of their
content because of this right now i mean
100 i think well i think they're also
you know in some ways they're hedging
their bets right they've got people who
are you know transphobic and they've got
people who they've featured specials who
are
you know uh people from that community
right uh or within the lgbtq uh
community
that they've they've put on they've they
lift it up through a platform so i think
in some ways they are hedging because
they're like listen
we're losing a lot of people
in terms of viewers and subscribers
we're not making as much money so if we
like send some send some people down uh
down the river to go look at the
transphobic stuff we send some people
down the river to go look at the more
like uh appropriate you know correct
things that are being said but the other
thing too is like
as a comedian
the worst
cheapest [ __ ] go-to thing
is to put down
to punch down a marginalized community
as you said a group that doesn't have
the majority or at least the voice of
the majority to say hey you know what
i'm gonna put you guys already a victim
of everyday
hate speech and crimes i'm going to make
you now the target of my special that i
was paid millions
for the rights of or partner with this
streaming service like netflix i'm going
to use my platform instead of saying
commentary on something else right on
on talking about how you know these
rights are taken away or this group is
being marginalized or these these people
are being persecuted instead of actually
taking the opportunity to say i can
punch up to the group that is punching
down
instead i'm going to punch down on these
people because i'm going to go for the
cheap laugh
because that is the
the the the thing that people will go
for and when you have comedians that do
that it's disgusting it is cheap it is
vile it is people buy it people people
buy it people 100 percent and don't get
it twisted people they're they they are
going to again the community that hates
ricky gervais for being an outright
atheist are going to love him for this
and i don't know if that was the aim i
don't think ricky gervais wrote these
jokes and aim for that i i i know after
the dave chappelle scandal with netflix
i'm sure they knew these jokes were
there yeah i mean i'm sure
i'm sure they knew but i want to go back
to one of the comedic geniuses of all
time have you watched the new carlin
documentary on hbo max i have not it is
on my to watch list it is it is
absolutely [ __ ] fantastic i i watched
it front to back yeah i've heard
kelly carlin uh his daughter did a great
job um carlin if you guys don't know if
you guys can't tell karlin has a big
influence on me and my commentary
because carlin i believe is more of a
commentator than he is a comedian at
certain parts of his career
because of some of the stuff that carlin
went through and and how he transitioned
to his career and the documentary does a
great job of explaining that um i don't
view myself as a comedian i view myself
as a commentator who uses comedy who
makes you laugh who who uses those those
things to make you think uh about
certain issues the way that maybe you
should or shouldn't or maybe a new way
of thinking about something right a new
perspective on it
but george garland
really did always try to punch up with
his comedy he explains it really well
here on this archive footage from cnn on
larry king live he's talking about
uh um
i i just lost the name holy moly uh i'll
i'll get it here in a second um but he's
he's talking about another comedian who
was punching down on poor people at the
time and he's talking i know he's
talking about he's talking about um
uh he's wears glasses and he's got a
leather jacket and
i lost it i lost it he's the guy that
twinkle twinkle little star how i wonder
what you are
as i um sit in this parking lot and eat
my girlfriend's you know um that's his
that's his stick is the bra oh bang
but anyways um let's listen to what
um carlin says about punching down in
comedy and remember this is from
many many years ago about 30 years ago
and george dice clay that's it nice clay
elon musk we're going to get the elon
musk here today so stick around that guy
but let's listen to what carlin says
about punching up and punching down in
comedy i would defend to the death his
right to do everything he does the thing
that i find unusual and it's you know
it's not a criticism so much but his
targets are underdogs and comedy
traditionally has picked on people in
power people who abuse their power women
and gays and immigrants are kind of to
my way of thinking underdogs and you
know he ought to be careful because he's
jewish and a lot of the people who want
to pick on these kind of groups the jews
are on that list a little further you've
got women gays gypsies
and suddenly you find jews and and then
leander was arrested yeah so uh you know
i i mean obviously he should do what he
wants and uh why does he get away with
it do you think then he has never
laughed at jokes about this well he's
appealing i think he's appealing largely
i think his core audience uh now listen
to this this is very important because
this has not changed and this is i think
what you were saying earlier about
appealing to different audiences not
just gervais but netflix in general core
audience are young white males who are
threatened by these groups i mean a lot
of these guys aren't sure their manhood
because that's a problem when you're
going in through adolescence you know am
i really i mean could i be i hope i'm
not one of them and the women who assert
themselves and are competent are a
threat to these men and so are
immigrants in terms of jobs and and uh
and so that's why we as an audience then
will laugh you say we i don't think you
mean i don't know but i think you're
collectively i think that's what what is
at the core of that experience that
takes place in these arenas there's a
certain uh
you know a sharing of of uh anger and
rage at these these targets and i'm sure
andrew isn't that angry at them i'm sure
he's playing it as a comic
and and george is doing the best he can
here to just to to express
that andrew has the right to say these
things and he's talking about andrew
dice clay just like ricky treveas has
the right to go out on stage and say
whatever he wants he absolutely has that
right and we shouldn't take that right
away from him
to be a hateful [ __ ] bigot if that's
what he wants to portray himself as
right and that's what carlin is trying
to say here is that hey andrew you can
do what you want but when you do these
things they have consequences words have
consequences words have actions right
and no one probably understood that
better than george carlin who at one
time was arrested for saying curse words
on stage right which is a famous bit
that he goes into right which is the
seven things you can't say on tv right
and and it goes through it in the
documentary and really if you're a
george carlin fan or even
don't don't know a lot of george
carlin's comedy but you've seen some
clips on twitter you definitely should
go watch the documentary
it is worth noting in the documentary as
as much accolades as people give carlin
for being such a brilliant mind and such
a smart person and to get us to think
and it's at its delivery of comedy
how damaged of a human he actually was
right and how all of us are not perfect
and we must remember that we must
remember that we're not all of us are
perfect and and we we should seek
we should seek perfection where
imperfection lies and i think that's
what george garland did the best and and
again i'm not getting paid to promote
the
the documentary but i love carlin he's
one of my favorite comedians him and
pryor and eddie murphy are some of my
favorite comedians of all time
and um
carlin as anyone can tell is a huge
influence on the things that i do uh on
a day-to-day basis and how i talk and
how i speak and how i express my
commentary so
go go watch that documentary if you have
a chance it's great i'll make sure to
i'll make sure to tell judd apatow when
we go have lunch later today oh okay
good good yeah let's let judd know that
i need my my soros checked yeah i know
for sure for sure when he gets but it is
it is amazing to see how george carlin
again not to be like he is the suit
sayer right right predicted but his
commentary is pretty accurate and again
it is unfortunate that we have people
who for cheap laughs and easy money will
punch down on a marginalized community
because hey
it's an easy laugh right
so you know that's the it's the world we
live in and unfortunately you still live
in that world where he nails it on the
head which is these young white men
are you know threatened unsure of where
they stand you know in the world that
they're in you know they're losing their
manly hood and they feel like they're
the victim and we see that again and
again again and it is so true and the
people that followed trump through the
presidency and have continued to follow
him to this day where these men these
white men are either
uh
throwing themselves to be the victim
after they've already committed some
sort of hate crime or you know the maga
uh
the maggot king mass shooter is another
example and then you got people like
marjory taylor green who are defending
white supremacists and anti-semites
because it's just a one it's just a
young white
kid
who exactly
george carlin is describing
right well and and i think
i think the attitude that george garland
has always had is that words have
consequences
and and words are action um and you
should punch up you should hold the
powerful accountable i mean that that is
what we should be doing with our words
and our actions and to be honest with
you ricky gervais and dave chappelle
they're they're not the powerful is to
be held accountable they should be
holding
they're powerful accountable and we're
making them too powerful if that makes
sense i mean remember comedians are
supposed to be the gestures of the court
right they are the people who are
supposed to be able to make fun of those
who are powerful right the king and the
queen and those who are ruling over
everyone else like the marjorie taylor
greens the lord
the people who are actually in power who
have an elected power they can they can
exert their power over us right
not you should be you should be adding
commentary and comedy and satire and
parody and just overall punditry
toward these people but not of the
people below you or of equal status
you should be making fun of that is not
how it should be the jester doesn't make
fun of the common people right he makes
fun of those who in the royal class the
ones who are actually ruling over
everyone else because they have the
ability to they are the ones who are
given kind of that veil of you know you
having it you have a a uh you get a jail
free card essentially right now you can
make the commentary we can all joke
about it because everyone else can
relate to it
but if you attack one specific group and
allow these white young males to to be
in on the joke and laugh at the small
group you're you're hurting the problem
not helping it
right well speaking of uh
bringing truth to power and making fun
of powerful people um gabe
[Laughter]
our headline and our uh
explain what is going on because
um elon musk
this is not the first time he's stepped
in this before where he believes uh yeah
it has happened in the past where
somebody has shared an article and he
has commented on it as if the article
was truth right
and in today's situation
elon musk
is replying psy
to an article that was written in
breitbart
about how dark money
bill gates
are all coming together to attack elon
musk
elon musk is the victim exclusive bill
gates poured millions into dark money
funding attacking elon musk
elon's like i'm just a white guy i
didn't do anything wrong it's not like i
it's not like i sexually assaulted and
tried to trade hand jobs for horses on a
spacex corporate jet yeah don't think
about that think about how bill gates is
trying to get me
right i'm the victim here i'm the i'm
the victim
i'm i'm the one who is being persecuted
persecuted right by these elites like
bill gates it seems like this seems like
what george garland was just talking
about right
i mean this this really is at truth to
power you know because elon hears that
this guy bill gates who is another
person that we should clown the hell out
of right like we should clown bill gates
he is the powerful we should hold him
accountable through comedy and through
satire and parody i mean that's true the
power is to him but for this guy
for this guy to act like he's the common
you know man and bill gates is out to
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
because this is not the first time just
in the last week that he fell for this
[ __ ] what did he fall didn't he fall for
something last week is that kind of the
same there was a yeah there was another
i gotta look up exactly what it was but
i remember it being another article on
somebody being like you know people
calling him out or but also people like
oh my god can you believe it he he's
it's he's telling the truth can you
believe this is
this is an exclusive wide spread you
know it's like no
somebody somebody wrote something
uh under the assumption
and also you know
uh
drawing a line between a lot of random
dots here and trying to come up with
some conspiracy and then elon comes in
and goes
yep that is how it is and it's like nope
it's not
well
i just want to remind everybody out
there that's listening
that uh elon
does not
he does he does not enjoy and he will
never he will never own twitter um he
might only hate her stock but he will
not we are now
it is may 24th yeah we are now one month
i believe the deal was signed
april 25th that's when the paperwork
april 25th 26th is when the paperwork
went through so we are now one month
later
okay and as a result
the stock has plummeted
from 998
to
you're talking about tesla yeah yeah
yeah
629
that is less than where we left it on
friday and as a friday elon musk had
lost a total net worth
of around 66 billion and that price was
at i believe it was 10
10 or no maybe 40 dollars higher um
when you look at the price if i look at
friday right now the end price was
around
663
i believe is what it was
and now it's 16. how's twitter doing
since he made his offer of was it like
54 dollars a share it was 5420 is what
he made the offer for right because he
tried to make a 420 joke out of it
and i tried to say at that point there's
no way he's going to buy right now and
twitter now due to his own reckless
behavior
has now dropped down to 36.21
oh
so that seems like a really bad
financial i mean for elon musk to be the
most brilliant financial mind in the
world right you think he'd look for any
reason he possibly could to get out of
this um get out of this because it seems
to me that the 54-20 that he would pay
versus what it's worth he would lose a
hell of a lot more money than if he just
took the yeah
we're talking you know 36-22 to 54-20
we're talking a delta of 18
right now as of this moment
you know i don't know how that i don't
know what the actual total shares are in
terms of what the actual
value is um to do the math right now but
i can tell you that that is a
significant
loss
in the value of what she was paying you
know the only people who are making out
like on this are are twitter and and
those who are twitter shareholders right
the board and every the execs these
people are like popping bottles because
even last week as of
uh mid last week at the end of last week
that you know essentially popped
champagne and said the price is what it
is we are not changing the price we are
committed to the agreement that we made
on april 25th and the agreements that we
signed you signed it we signed it
if you're gonna pay us you're either
paying us the 44 billion or you're
paying us a billion and if you try to
fight it we're going to take you to
court which means you'll probably have
to settle so it may not be a whole
billion or it also could be over a
billion because you've also got to pay
the legal fees to cover what twitter
costs to go to jail or to to go to court
well so go to jail
i don't know if that means like go to
the barn to get a horse right
yourself out with a bale of hate right
maybe maybe what he does is he goes to
the twitter headquarters and he promises
a whole fleet of horses that he can
he's like listen listen
hold your horses okay
i'm not that stable right now oh my god
stop stop
i can't you want to keep going
well
a really good point here says remember
on 5 20 20 22 which was only four days
ago yeah tony and gabe predicted that
elon musk would get booted from tesla
and i said on that day i give it 90 days
i gave you 90 days that he would lose
his position and tesla because here's
what i think gabe i think he'll never
own twitter i mean he may own stock but
he'll never own two when he owns the
nine nine or so percent or whatever
right he's never gonna own twitter he's
gonna lose his his position at tesla
over this because he's a [ __ ]
bonehead right um he's a he's a dum-dum
he's a dummy he's a [ __ ] idiot if
you've ever listened to any interview of
him trying to talk about something he
uses word salad he literally he is
trying to become trump that was his
whole [ __ ] thing in the first place
he never wanted to own twitter he just
wanted to be the trump of twitter he
wanted to be the pied piper of all these
[ __ ] trumped up white dudes that's it
these incels and he didn't realize
he didn't realize and he didn't do the
[ __ ] math in his head because he is a
[ __ ] idiot he's not a good business
person he's a [ __ ] he is not
intelligent he just so happens to have a
silver spoon in his mouth and he's
stolen in intellectual property from
other [ __ ] and he's been able
to buy that property and act like it's
his own and he invented it
elon musk elon musk miscalculated
when he thought that maga
was his customers at tesla and he
totally [ __ ] miscalculated that point
and tesla the [ __ ] investors the
company the employees are gonna pay a
huge price for this and i think elon
musk is too and i think they're gonna
fire him from that position i've heard
this you can't fire him he owns it get
the [ __ ] out of here that ain't how
public companies work have you ever
heard of [ __ ] steve jobs and apple
you are a dumb [ __ ] but it's
also it's also not just public companies
like you look at the situation like so
like on april april 27th is when i i ran
through the hypothetical let's run
through a hypothetical situation which
is like if he does this he's got to come
up with money the money is going to come
out of tesla because that is the most
liquid asset he has
to get money to actually pay for the
deal to cover his end of the financing
which by the way is still
not secure just want to point that out
for everyone who's listening and also i
guy
financing is not secure and i wouldn't
be surprised that because of the way
that the stock has gone down i wouldn't
be surprised if the stock hits 540 or
lower well he's lost more goddamn money
than what he offered twitter exactly
we're talking over the deal is 44
billion and he's lost over what now it
well 66 billion on friday i'm we're
talking somewhere in the 70s if not more
than that potentially by the end of the
week but the thing that remember here is
on april 27th when i said let's run
through the hypothetical
if he does this the board's already
frustrated so are the stockholders so
what's going to happen is he could
potentially have a vote of no confidence
when he which means he is ousted as
tesla ceo now the other thing that
people need to remember is that not
only does it happen in public companies
but it also will happen in a private
company before a company goes public
right you can be ousted
uber
we work these are both examples doesn't
mean that it doesn't mean that just
because you own the company the company
and the board can't look at you and go
you're out [ __ ] you're not
interested
yeah exactly you are not in the best
interest you are you are losing money
here you are making this a problem for
us yes the company
is full on
your brand right you are tied you know
you've got uh you've got adam newman
with with with uh wework he is the brand
right there they are they're tied
together was his his enthusiasm and his
energy and his his uh aggressive
expansion tactics that got them to where
there was however it was also
the demise that took him down right like
that was his demise that was what that
was what happened the same thing
happened with uh with uh travis who is
the ceo of uber before these company
these companies even went public they
were ousted because they were a thorn in
the company side and they were actually
a toxic
a toxic uh root and
yeah take it out build the company well
crystal crystal says here
must misread the room and i think it's i
think you're right crystal but i think
it's well beyond that i think he sent
out a tweet
he he got a lot of response because he's
a he's a [ __ ] in-cell bonehead who's
on the internet all the time who [ __ ]
loves his in-cell army and they
convinced him that he can't puss out on
this thing he's really got to stay in it
so that he can keep up this stupid
[ __ ] red pill image whatever he's
trying to promote on [ __ ] social
media platforms which he's duped all
these dumb [ __ ] into thinking
he's some kind of red pill person it's
really it really is stupid because we
see
this same situation that crystal says a
musk misreading the room when he gets
his [ __ ] dick out to try to have
someone jerk him off and he says i'll
buy you a horse like this this is this
is who elon is and i tried to tell you
[ __ ] this i tried to say it
from the beginning he will not own
twitter it is all [ __ ] he's lying to
you he's full of [ __ ] [ __ ] all of it
the whole [ __ ] caboodle anytime this guy
opens his mouth he is full of [ __ ] he's
full of it he's [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
full stop that's just what it is yeah i
mean this is just another example of
icarus flying too close to the sun
hubris
is a hell of a drug it is and that is
ultimately what brings these people down
they get power they have ego they
believe that they can do anything they
can do no wrong they say something on
twitter they get stuck and cornered they
feel like they have to commit so they
don't feel weak and then what ends up
happening he [ __ ] himself over he loses
more net worth than the actual deal
itself
and it actually continues to just fall
and fall and fall until
you know he's potentially ousted at the
company and here's the thing i don't
know what tesla knew about spacex or if
this other stuff happens at tesla you
know because here's the thing if there's
one example or one incident of this
happening i'm sure there's probably
others right and his companies obviously
breed that jim crow era frat house type
of environment and that's just you know
based on 46 lawsuits at uh at tesla
spacex has multiple on its own i mean
there were more lawsuits filed in in
2021
for
discrimination both uh gender and race
than there were in any other year in the
18 years that tesla's been around so for
people to be like oh it is what it is
and that's how it is blah blah blah like
bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
this company
is is becoming to be an issue because
of elon musk
it it and we're going to move on to some
more truth to power [ __ ] but really
honestly
um for anyone to take anything that elon
musk says going forward from here on out
uh seriously
rather it be someone at a board on a
company or investors or anyone they
really are they really do deserve what's
coming to them to believe anything that
[ __ ] says are the sycophant for
him in any [ __ ] way shape or form he
is a dumb [ __ ] i don't even care if he
starts saying liberal [ __ ] again he's a
dumb [ __ ] to me he's full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] always has been always will be and
he's always got his finger on the sail
that's all it is he just is feeling the
wind and his wind on social media has
always been these trumped up white dudes
vinnie loco asked where do i get the hat
yeah where do you get that hat now you
just go to the tonymichaels.com and if
you go to the tonymichaels.com there's
the hat store there there's another
merch store gabe's merch store is there
as well he's got some good um some i got
to make i got yeah i got to make some
new some new merch too yeah well we need
to do doubt me everyone wants the dump
me shirts
we got to come up with the doubt me
shirts yeah um we'll have to come up
with that
uh speaking of of uh
doubting someone this is uh moe brooks
who who got doubted by donald trump you
know trump actually endorsed mo brooks
and then when mo brooks is like ah
trump's kind of an [ __ ] he's uh crazy
and i'm not gonna go down this train
because there might be some criminal
liability right brooks basically lost
donald trump's endorsement but here in
this video he has ted cruz
uh endorsing him but ted cruz says
donald trump's name a lot in this video
gabe my question is we're gonna watch
this video it's only 15 seconds long but
my question is before we watch this
do you think that ted cruz practices
this in the mirror because this is not
the first time i've watched him do this
in a video but do you think he practices
let's watch and then you can yeah yeah
let me
on earth professes their allegiance to
president trump i love donald trump no
no i love donald trump even more no no i
have donald trump tattooed on my rear
end
uh what do you think jesus it was you
know what dude this was [ __ ]
hilarious the first time i heard this
joke
um
you call it a joke uh he as well i mean
look cruz is a [ __ ] i i give this
challenge out to someone on the internet
right now
find me
one
funny
conservative comedian and i'll give you
five bucks i will send you five bucks on
venmo but i guarantee you can't do it
i guarantee it now ted cruz here i i
wholeheartedly believe that he's got a
full body length mirror and he's like
heidi heidi check this out i got this
new bit you know and she's like i think
he'd bring snowflake in too to [ __ ]
torture that dog again oh i am sure
snowflake has claw marks on the door
trying to get out but i'm sure he goes
in the room he's like heidi look i got
this new bit i got this new bit and
she's like is it um
is it the whole like tattoo on the butt
thing and she goes he's like yeah but
but but i i got it even better now it's
even better i promise and she's like
okay i guess i'm forced into this
marriage here so let's do it you know
and he continues and continues his you
know his children are like okay dad we
get it it's it was not funny the first
time
i guarantee he makes his family sit to
that joke as he practices late into the
hours his neighbors are like keep it
down ted and he's like i'm working on
this joke and they're like it wasn't
funny the first like everyone is telling
him it's not funny and he does it he did
it before and people like ha ha that's
so good you know
and then he does it again with mo brooks
and it's like dude
it's not even a one hit it's wonderful
it's a one-hit mistake it's a well
here's the thing because he he went i
think he went and did it with josh
mandel up in oh yeah yeah
yeah he was he was yeah he was he was
trumping for him because he was like oh
you know these people these people and
he's like
uh
josh mandel is the real friend for
jefferson
mandela is the real trump candidate i
know even though trump did endorsed his
cousin jd mandel not actually jd it's
weird here's another clip of of ted cruz
sick of fanning for mo brooks here nah
it's only 20 seconds let's watch this
the reason i'm here is because i've seen
this man stand and fight he's talking
about mo brooks stand and fight the guy
with the flak jacket on at january 6th
so this means that
this video would make me feel that ted
cruz is now against donald trump because
he's supporting someone
that donald trump is against but nobody
know brooks but gabe he stood in fought
with his flak jacket on for donald trump
right but donald trump was like
uh mo brooks never heard of him hope
that guy [ __ ] loses his race
which it appears that mo brooks is
actually gonna win here which i actually
think that's what ted cruz is doing
right what ted cruz is doing is he's
going around all these trump sycophants
who aren't endorsed by trump and he's
going and he's stumping for them because
as soon as one of them wins which it
looks like uh it looks like mo brooks
may win here in alabama right so if mo
brooks wins
what ted cruz now gets is i'm better
than trump right like right i'm i win
more races than trump and he's only has
to win one well he's like it's he's like
it's the ted cruz touch right exactly
the ted cruz touch
the ted cruz touch yeah well
ugh that's worse than
having to sit on a plane with him on the
way to cancun let's listen to ted cruz
talks cheap
but listen if you say
you support the second amendment great
when and you stood and fought and bled
to defend the second amendment
who is he talking about here that's
stood and fought and bled for the second
amendment
i mean it seems a little weird
considering the fact that people like mo
brooks said hey you shouldn't do this
this whole insurrection might not be a
good idea even though i'm going to speak
at the rally and then afterward i'm
going to talk about how i told trump he
couldn't overturn the election
right
uh it's it seems like he's he's feeding
into the people that
wanted to show up or support the people
that stormed the capital and smeared
[ __ ] on the walls
he is doing that he definitely is for
smearing [ __ ] somewhere
ted cruz you say you support securing
the border great
show me your record of when you've stood
and fought and bled to secure the ball
what the [ __ ] is he talking about stood
and fought and bled what does he ha does
he think these people actually believe
that ted cruz went down in the border
with this [ __ ] dunlap hanging over
his belt pointing across the fence
acting like he's blessed
it honestly it it makes me think that
cruz is like he's like listen i need my
my my my militia men i need them down to
the border and i need them defending the
border from any sort of invader right
like who is who is he talking to what
border the canadian border the the
mexican border he knows more about the
canadian border than he knows about the
texas or the texas border mexican border
yeah because he's from again look he's
crossed both borders he has crossed both
borders there's nothing wrong with being
from canada yeah i know another wrong
great bacon awesome right but
i will say really honestly they they're
inviting that people to come
you know they have liberty there like if
you guys need to leave right come come
on up we have health care and we've got
other benefits that are going on you can
make your own choices in health care if
you're a woman that's right exactly i
mean i mean very much like handmade
stale canada is the actual
land in which you are free from the
the tyranny
of america
but i don't know what i don't know who
ted cruz is talking to if he's calling
on you know people to to to defend their
second amendment right and go down and
and man the border themselves
and actually you know commit crimes in
the name of jesus of course well of
course why the hell wouldn't it be in
the name of jesus right
how couldn't we have something in the
name of jesus um
there's a guardian article minus robin
send it to me people are talking about
it in the chat here about um have you
heard this uh scotus decision
where they're um and i don't know the
legal term maybe we should have kfa or
popock on to give us more deep depth
into this
but apparently they are trying to make
it to where
um there is there is no appeals process
for wrongful convictions in a state
court so before if you watch like making
a murderer
if you watch that documentary series on
netflix which is a kind of uh you know
salacious in some points but there's one
part um
about the the
the main character's nephew who's also
in prison for murder right yeah um and
his name is escaping my mind right now
but that he actually has tried to use
the federal courts in an appeal way to
appeal the state decision
of putting him up for capital murder
right for a wrongful conviction which
seems to be
you know all [ __ ] well yeah i mean
if you watch the documentary and then
you would look at the just the the
interrogation right
minor
coerce into saying something right right
he was not of the right mind you know
well right and not not not really a
proven to not be an intelligent child
right right and this isn't this is this
actually is a huge problem a right a
massive problem when it comes to the
tactics and protocol especially cops
back then people i mean cops today
with not just with people of color
marginalized i mean the central park
five is another example of them
uh not doing things legally
to get critical confessions
and then use that as as as evidence to
convict these five innocent children
right basically what the supreme court
is doing here is taking away the ability
um and and from what i understand there
was not really a case involved in this
this had something something else to do
and these uh these bought and paid for
federal society fascists that we have on
the court um they just decided well
we're not gonna let people who are
wrongfully convicted appeal to the
federal government
um
to overturn
what may seem to be wrongful convictions
by the state of which they're imprisoned
in and which they're incarcerated which
um
it seems to be gabe that
they're trying which we know in this
country
people of color and marginalized
communities are charged with more
capital crimes
and probably wrongful convictions than
any other community out there
and it really does seem to be another
chipping away at america's rights
america's liberty um
you know i'm not saying
that we should let people who have
committed heinous violent crimes right
out in the streets but we should give
them the appeal process
regardless of what you believe or if
they did it or they didn't do it those
people should have an appeals process in
this country yeah they should have an a
the ability to go through the courts and
and seek refuge in our court system if
there is evidence
that an appeals court believes that they
are wrongfully convicted we definitely
should do that you should have the right
to do that all the way up until
the the very last day of your sentence
or the day that you die you should
definitely have that right to appeal
i i actually don't think if we're going
to keep people in prison for a really
long time i don't think we should even
stop you know at some point
people's appeals run out i don't think
we should run out you should be able to
keep appealing
um that's just the way it should be if
we're gonna be so hell-bent on keeping
people in prison and imprisoning people
especially non-violent criminals uh the
way that we do ex especially with drugs
um yeah we really need to we really need
to do something about in this country
about our criminal justice system and
the court system and this
un
goes a step in the wrong direction which
is not surprising from this fascist uh
bought and paid for federal society
court right it's not surprising that
they would make
make this decision so maybe maybe i'll
try to see if we can if the audience
wants we can try to see if we can get
pop
our kfa karen agnipolo from legal af on
to give us a little more rundown of what
this actually means legally because
there's a couple legal terms in here
that i'm really not sure exactly what
they mean but it really does seem like
this stripping of this appeal
um from people who may be wrongfully
convicted it really does seem
unconstitutional it really does seem to
be against american values and america
what we think of right as american
values before we go i do want to bring
something up that people are talking
about in the chat there's an active
active shooter right now we're in texas
at rob elementary school in uvalde uh i
i don't know if i'm saying that right
vivaldi texas
to something yeah yeah they can pull up
i can send you this right now
so you're saying it's in texas and an
elementary school
yeah it is uh west of
uh san antonio a little bit southwest of
san antonio
um jesus christ um
so i have i have um a daughter who is
in second grade and today is their field
day
and i always hate i always say you know
it's a fun day it's their last week of
school they're gonna have fun today
i always hate and and i hate that i have
to have this feeling that
my children um are not safe at a school
and here is more um
just more of this
nonsense that we have to put up in this
country and it is that we put up with it
because we could do something about this
here's the headline um
what is this b and o news is that a
local news station down there in in
texas
uh i
believe so
so it looks like it is active shooter at
rob elementary is what they're reporting
um
do they have someone in custody or
right now i'm not seeing that it just
see it says the the rest of the district
is under a secure status details about
what happened we're not immediately
clear but mayor don mclaughlin told fox
news that at least one person was shot
after which the shooter ran into the
school the situation's ongoing and the
shooter is barricaded inside several
people in the area reported hearing
gunfire but it's unclear whether any
shots were fired inside the school
itself a large number of emergency
servers have been called to the scene
while officers work to secure the scene
it's saying here that the
the active shooter rob elementary there
is one and law enforcement
is on site is what the school district
is confirming um here in this report
um um and to
answer your question b o news sorry it's
not local um there are other ones as
well as i can pull up is
yeah this is a global kind of news let's
see if we can um
look up rob
elementary here
and see if we can find yeah what is
going on
everyone is reporting we got new york
post reporting on it now and
you know uh the actual school district
has tweeted out there's an active
shooter robin elementary law enforcement
is on site your cooperation is neat at
this time by not visiting the campus as
soon as more information is gathered it
will be shared the rest of the district
is under a secure status
uh two minutes ago someone at ap is
reporting
that there are no immediate reports of
injuries
um is what it's saying so
it sounds like someone maybe fired a gun
but it and at this point from the ap
report that was
put out just a few minutes ago um
there's no immediate reports of injuries
um let's see if we can find something
else here
[Music]
and again this is an ongoing story so we
try to bring you stories like this as
they happen if we can
we are not a news organization but we do
comment on the news right and let me
tell you something this is
um our own problem
this is our problem as a country
and if you don't think this is more of a
reason to pay attention to who you're
voting for and why you're voting for
those people and i'm not just talking
about president or
governor or your congress person i'm
talking about all the way down to your
school board now how they react to this
what their views are on this um this
stuff is very important our children are
not safe in this country even at the
most safe
what we think of is the safest place
that they can be is an elementary school
i mean that hasn't been proven to you
over the years
then you are not paying attention you
you are not what we call woke and really
you really need to pluck your head out
of your ass and realize that this is an
american problem this is our problem as
the citizens to solve nra isn't going to
help us the [ __ ] politicians aren't
going to help us they're not
these current policymakers that we have
are not and so we need to change the the
paradigm here and we need to shift the
paradigm
to people who will help us fix this
problem um and government isn't the
solution for everything it's not
but we see with the the buffalo manga
king mass shooter in that instance
he was under psych evaluation after
threatening a school shooting
and he still was able to legally buy
three weapons
after he was under
mental psych evaluation after
threatening to shoot and kill people at
his school
this is not this is not something that
we can't do anything about we are not
doing anything about it that is the
problem we are standing by and letting
the gun manufacturers and the people who
profit off weapons in this country
absolutely [ __ ] spread delusion about
what is reality and what is not
and it is killing our children and
putting them in [ __ ] danger and not
just our children adults too but how in
the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ] after newtown
after babies
babies are being [ __ ] murdered
that we can't we can't figure out that
hey
hey maybe
maybe just maybe we shouldn't let
elementary schools
have bullets flying around where little
children are being executed
we probably shouldn't do that
and how we can't come to terms with that
and realize that that we are the ones
who can do something and you can you can
today if you're in these states there
are people on the ballot who right now
are for pro-democracy and for democracy
to to tell the rest of the country
and the majority of ideology in this
country who want background checks who
do not want some of these weapons on the
street who do not want some of these
modifications that they're manufacturing
for these weapons
there are people out there that want
those policies
and you can do something about it you
can by using your voice at the ballot
box that is the most important thing
because let me tell you something gabe
these 2a fools these trumped up white
dudes
who believe oh we should own tanks and
rockets and bombs and all this [ __ ]
these insurrectionists these
seditionists these fascists
if you don't go vote they're they're
going to and they're going to vote for
the ones that are making sure that these
weapons are available for people to go
to elementary schools like this one in
texas
and to shoot and kill other human beings
and if you're if you're not paying
attention
we are in trouble you have to start
paying attention to these issues it is
the most the most important thing to
remember here is that
these people on the local level they
will trickle up
right these people who are obviously
anti-democracy and pro-fascism and
taking away your rights here and
marrying kids there and banning books
here
these people start at low levels right
they're going to be your county
commissioners and they're going to
trickle up to higher positions and those
people that made those laws or made
those policies on a local level that if
that impacts you and your district and
the school or impacts your county where
you live or wherever it is those people
will begin to rise up and those people
will make those similar laws if not more
extreme laws that are more controlling
to a larger population and the only way
to fight that is to stop it early
and the only way we can stop it early is
to show up and vote
now there is a couple conflicting
reports i want to re reiterate that we
are only getting news um as it comes in
it appears some news outlets are
reporting that one person was shot but
some news outlets are saying that no one
was injured
which if someone was shot and actually
struck by um
um
a bullet then then they probably would
be injured i would imagine so there is
some conflicting reports so um pay
attention we'll probably stay on this
story and make sure we send out some
tweets for our listeners uh later on so
make sure to follow us on all the social
media platforms at tonymichaelspod
follow us on youtube twitter and twitch
we will be back here tomorrow as we are
every weekday monday through friday
90 excuse me noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific
on youtube twitter twitch make sure to
follow us there um also we simulcast on
minus touch facebook page gabe we didn't
get to it today we'll have to get to it
tomorrow we really need to work on this
schedule me and gabe will work on um the
hearing schedule yeah yeah these public
hearings we kind of have sort of what we
thought there was supposed to be
any time at six years it was supposed to
be eight and i was six and you know it's
not the best of times but well and i
think i think um maybe some of these
will be more pointed in that direction i
don't know so and i we also don't know
the length of time in which they're
going to be so well they kind of
estimated that they'd be a few hours but
four in the morning summer in the
afternoon in prime time it's gonna be
very early for me
yes yeah eight a.m which is five a.m
over here
yeah assuming they go east coast time
you'll soda stream through it you'll
soda i
carbonated water his carb water actually
this one is this is just tap water today
i'm sorry guys let you down didn't
stream while streaming whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa i know
although i didn't even notice you know
didn't even notice that you weren't you
know but i had to be true true to myself
and let everyone else know authentic
authentic non-sodastreaming
yeah well
until tomorrow um our authenticity will
have to wait until then gabe um till
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
youtube twitter twitch uh keep out for
some uh news on this breaking active
shooter in texas we will try to keep up
with that on our accounts over on the
socials until tomorrow surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules no boundaries i think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking